a stunning at mission even Hillary
Clinton confesses that the media kept
her husband's presidency afloat when he
and his unbuttoned trousers should have
been sent packing at a Clinton
Foundation event marking the 25th
anniversary of the 92 election I wasn't
invited
she said bill wouldn't have survived if
Fox News was around our body politics
immune system has been impaired because
there has been a concerted effort
starting with the creation of the Fox
Network it wasn't there when Bill first
ran it was one of the reasons he
probably survived boy he looks thrilled
he's saying please shoot me now she
makes this claim while many in the media
now admit that bill should have resigned
after the Winsky scandal so isn't
Hillary agreeing with these new critics
by saying that fnc wouldn't have let
bill slide but the media monopoly did so
without knowing it hillary exposed the
media's lack of guts while saluting
fox's it's hilarious
hmm she also claims that bill wouldn't
have tweeted about his achievements as
president someone should tell her
twitter wasn't around back then
hillary twitter wasn't around back then
but what a blind-spot she has to think
that not tweeting makes bill a man of
sound character he violated an intern in
the Oval Office sorry I take the
tweeting instead which raises the
question what if fnc and twitter had
been around back then when bill was
president how would that have changed
things twitter would have kept bill busy
and Fox would have kept him in line and
perhaps Hillary would have ended a
president how hilarious is that if Fox
News was around Hillary would have been
president instead bill got away with all
sorts of crap as the media covered for
him and now they call him on it years
later only because there's no
consequence
you can't throw a bomb out that's been
out for 17 years so Hillary I'm glad you
enjoyed the party at the Clinton
Foundation
I hope the Russia picked up the tab and
someone besides bill brought the cigars
so is that theta isn't this the irony is
that she's coming out against two things
that if they existed probably would have
paved the way for her presidency because
if they had if Clinton had been
impeached and resigned that would have
given them more moral authority to go
after somebody like Trump yeah well and
also I absolutely think that Bill
Clinton would have used Twitter if it
had been around oh absolutely
at least to pick up girls really
interesting to spend the weekend
listening to a lot of commentary and
reading people have sort of revisionist
history of what it was like in 1997 I
just remember it's very specifically for
for me I was 23 years old I was working
for a member of Congress and I was
sitting there watching us and like
surely somebody's going to defend this
woman right like surely they're not
going to absolutely just throw her under
the bus and it never happened and
they're doing it now and then you see
hear them say well things are different
now look well what is actually different
yeah the only thing that's different is
there's a different president in the
Oval Office maybe the fact that we're
like exposed basically every media
sector or technology sector economic
sector is affected by this problem of
sexual harassment but I always thought
about that as a young girl as an intern
it was his responsibility and they all
covered for him and so now in 1992 they
were looking back it can't be that
people were so blind at the time is that
they were willfully blind yeah it was
not a big deal could we show another
this is another clip of Hillary talking
about Trump which is hilarious
apparently you know my former opponent
is obsessed with my speaking out
apparently there was another somebody
told me tweet today honestly between
tweeting and golfing how does he get
anything done I don't understand it
so maybe that's maybe that's the whole
point well you know it Kimberly
but you know why because she's saying
you know if you know he's tweeting and
golfing how does he get anything done
that's indirectly at Bill Clinton if he
had been doing other things he wouldn't
have been doing other people golfed and
tweeted more if there were treated
existed he would probably have not would
have had idle fingers yes exactly I
wasn't thinking that but I mean that's
why it's good there's five of us here on
the I was watching bill in his body
language yes no he's right away picked
up the microphone it was body Morse code
down yeah so he didn't love it so he was
picking it up and you know then
proceeded to try to like redirect and
turn it around because he doesn't like
when Hillary goes on these tangents and
also he's think don't you know poke the
president Trump cage and get him going
and then he'll start tweeting about us
again and he has no desire no bid to
have president Trump focused on him
right now I'll tell you that much
you know Jesse I think she she it she
insulted the media by saying she wished
for the good old days when there are
just a monopoly of patsies right
I mean Fox broke up the mainstream media
damn yeah monopolies and they haven't
been able to get over it Hillary reminds
me of a corrupt dictator that rigs an
election and then why's that she only
gets 90 percent of the vote it's not
enough to get fed debate questions by
CNN sounded off where Politico run the
stories by you so you can approve them
I mean ABC CBS NBC MSNBC CNN from all
the newspapers all the magazines
Facebook Twitter Google that's not
enough live that's not enough to carry
Hillary over the finish line maybe she
didn't deserve it and you're right
stunning admission she's saying if Fox
News was around we would have been fair
and balanced with the sex scandals but
she's also admitting that these sex
scandals were a vast right-wing
conspiracy that the women accusing her
husband right had no merit right I think
that's pretty sad and they went after
her after them yeah I mean there was an
absurd
to go after the women which is I guess
maybe maybe that is different now that
hopefully we don't do that anymore yeah
you want do you think she's not aware of
how the media are reconsidering their
role in the 90s did she just not follow
that first of all I just so strongly
disagree with you because it seems to me
I'm not surprised
well good because that's why we have a
show but I think but I mean what she
said was so obvious to me guess what the
news media today including Fox News
really caters to a specific portion of
the political people who are interested
in politics in this country and so you
have people who will confirm
pre-existing biases in the media whether
you're watching MSNBC Fox News or
whatever you tuned in to your favorite
talk radio show host that's the way it
works these days that's not the way it
worked back then what she said was that
currently in this media environment
people don't really care about the facts
they just want to hear but did he might
think confirm that's bad because the
fact is they didn't care about what they
did that's not true Bill Clinton was
impeached I don't know if you missed it
but impeach the media said it was just a
no that fox news was around during the
time of the impeachment and fox news was
highly critical of Bill come they
weren't around for Jennifer flowers the
nomination I don't well I think that a
literate president I don't think that's
what she's talking about but I think
she's talking about things like Monica
Lewinsky and by the way Monica Lewinsky
has said that was a consensual
relationship I think there was a great
imbalance in terms with a power ranger
right right but it but it's not like the
young woman was saying something wrong
happened in her opinion to her
personally so Monica and to Monica and
to all the other women very personally
well there was criticism of Hillary for
not leaving and for not throwing his
clothes out I think you've done that you
need a prince on her side she'd be
President it could I don't know I Barack
Obama but I know that this thing over
the weekend started with Donald Trump
Donald Trump saying she was the greatest
worst loser of all time
and then when she responds you go after
her I don't get out while you know it's
like my little sister
she used to punch me and punch me and
punch me all day and then when I finally
hit her back she'd go oh mom
Jesse hit me he's just counter you hit
her back I mean like horrible he this is
coming out of the papers tomorrow
nothing on Charlie Rose
well this Washington Post came out on
Charlie Rose today for walking around
naked in front of people well I'll tell
you if you want to take the Democrats
point of view though Gregory yeah go to
Kirsten Gillibrand getting the senator
from New York who took Hillary's seat I
think she'd been in the house two terms
makes Hillary see and now she's saying
Bill should acquit they should have
thrown him out what she could say that
now because there's no consequences oh
there is a consequence for Kirsten
Gillibrand because I think what you're
seeing I mean let me just tell you
something
Bill Clinton is immensely popular right
not only generally but inside the
Democratic Party very popular I think
his power and the power of Hillary
Clinton is waning
which is why Donna Brazile Kirsten
Gillibrand others can come out but boy
I'm just shocked I don't know what this
means for Kirsten Gillibrand's future
here in New York see I disagree wouldn't
you say that it means her futures up and
the Clinton dynasty is now a walking
corpse well and that's on purpose I mean
that's what I think the intention is to
say okay listen
enough is enough of these folks and
we've got to move forward with the party
and unless we address the skeletons
which is packed with Clinton skeletons
in the closet they're not going to be
able to do that and they want to have
longevity but trying to get some
elevation on the issue to say how do we
persist forward despite these scandals
and what's going on well it's not going
to be with the Clintons and especially
when you see now the coverage that it's
actually getting that it should have
before about Bill Clinton do you think
though it matters can because I mean
President Trump has his own issues and
it doesn't matter to his backers what
were there were people that made the
allegations and they had investigation
and where did any of that you know go I
mean except for the statement to Bush no
I think there are lots of people still
wondering when they'll get some justice
in terms of charges against Donald Trump
but I don't think it to his backers they
don't want to hear it okay what's going
through their appropriate channels of
due process and to see what in fact will
be adjudicated
people that have made audition I just
worry that we're in such partisan times
that people don't want to hear about
somebody that they support I think that
we were in partisan times before Fox was
around and then when Fox came it was
like oh wait there's another team that
isn't actually you know holding the
water for us I think that's what she was
saying I research so much easier having
these patsies what she was saying the
Fox is partisan and everybody else in
the mainstream media just want the facts
and that's not true
less where Dana anything well I just on
that point of the the allegations
against Charlie Rose that have just come
up and from the Washington Post I mean
we are at a point where there might be
no one there might be no bottom to this
and we're all racing to the bottom of it
and we just might be faster than others
and you just think you could pick up the
paper and every day it could be somebody
else so I think at some point the
conversation has to turn to okay then
what are we going to do in terms of some
sort of reconciliation or something that
says okay guys like so we've exposed you
like me to everybody raised their hand
like you all expose can we get to a
point then let me say okay so then
moving forward yes here on out we all
agree that sexual harassment is wrong
and moving forward and see if we can try
to get past this as a country we're also
learning that sexual harassment what he
called seminars
they're not working training do the
training isn't working they're looking
at the research and they're going it's
oh so we don't have to go next year yeah
exactly
okay I'll be been to four of them and
they're all the same don't you think
they're intended to protect the company
absolutely that's what it is it's not
it's not having anything right and
they're doing this but that's what this
contracting like that was for that's
good for the company but are you
actually getting something that
resonates where there's like teachable
moments and lessons that people embrace
and therefore engage in conduct change
going forward that is positive and
creates less of that environment so I'm
not going to the Christmas party